Громадський транспорт у Німеччині - серед найкращих у Європі.
За те, щоб ця система злагоджено функціонувала,
відповідають насамперед міські або регіональні комунальні транспортні об'єднання.
Вони фінансуються за рахунок придбаних квитків,
доходів від реклами і оренди, а також компенсацій від держави.
У Берліні, приміром, державні компенсації становлять
іноді половину доходів транспортних компаній.
Це робиться для того, щоб транспортні об'єднання
не підвищували різко тарифів,
і поїздки в автобусах і метро залишалися доступними для людей.
Вартість квитків складає в середньому 2-3 євро
і варіюється в залежності від дальності поїздки
та тривалості дії квитка.
Також держаними компенсаціями покривається безкоштовне
перевезення людей з інвалідністю,
пільгові квитки для учнів та студентів,
а також так звані соціальні проїздні, які коштують вдвічі дешевше звичайних -
для отримувачів соціальної допомоги.
Інвестиції у громадський транспорт держава робить також
шляхом фінансування модернізації або будівництва нової інфраструктури.
Загалом питання, повязані з функціонуванням транспортної системи,
перебувають у відомстві окремих федеральних земель.
Торік, за даними міністерства транспорту Німеччини,
федеральним землям надали близько 8 млрд євро дотацій
для фінансування громадського транспорту.
У майбутньому державні витрати на транспорт можуть зрости ще більше -
деякі німецькі міста розглядають можливість
зробити проїзд в автобусах і метро безкоштовним.
Так мерії сподіваються спонукати німців
ідмовитися від поїздок на авто і зменшити
рівень забруднення повітря. Утім, поки що
німці не знайшли формули, як втілити цю ідею,
щоб транспортні обєднання не збанкрутували.